we looked at reciprocal functions before
so this is y equals 1 over f of X we are
now I'm going to shift our focus to
squared functions so if you want to
write this in your top left hand corner
this is y equals taking an entire
function right and then multiplying it
by itself squaring it okay now really
quick note which I actually know what no
I'm gonna leave it to the end because I
have time for it we'll see if we've seen
second back okay just there was a
notation P so it's not that appointment
all right now again we're gonna think
about this entirely visually okay again
there are some important points and they
thankfully are quite in common with what
we had a look at before so for example
when is y equal to 0 here what x value
is it it's two so in y equals 0 what
happens when you not take the reciprocal
when you square 0 what happens you get 0
that's handy
what about 1 where is y equal to 1 can
you see it it's at x equals 3 right
what's the square of 1 it's just 1 right
ok now another important point we looked
at before was negative 1 the reciprocal
of negative 1 is negative 1 but we're
not thinking reciprocals right now we're
thinking about squares the square of
negative 1 is aa so see there's negative
1 down there right so therefore when I
Square this guy it's going to become 1
okay now now think about this for a
second you're 11 you're 11 think
carefully we're squaring this thing
right at least in the worlds that we
live in when you square something you
always get out a positive answer so in
this case unlike in the previous one I
don't really need to worry that same 2y
like this negative stuff right it's
actually going to once it's squared it's
going to be just like the positive stuff
right and let's just do a couple more
values just to be short right
we've got say enough space to do here
when x equals 4 y is equal to y is y is
equal to 2 so what's the square of 2
that's 4 there's 4 right up there ok
you can see there's a spot down there
down the bottom it's actually the
y-intercept y equals negative two so
when you square negative two you also
get four by oh hold on I'm getting some
symmetry here right now when you get
large values and you square them there
you get bigger let me say that again
large values when you square them they
get bigger but let's zoom look a little
more closely here and a spot like this
what's the Y value right here it's 1/2
0.5 right when you square a small value
like this it doesn't get bigger 1/2
times 1/2 is a water right it gets
smaller small values get smaller big
values get bigger right squaring it's
kind of like it's like Captain America
it's like that Super Soldier Serum it
makes the bad guy bad R and the good guy
anyway whatever so you see the same
things happening over here right you've
got negative 1/2 here what happens to
the negative I'm squaring so it's all
positive right but 1/2 times 1/2 gives
me a quarter it's this really teeny tiny
value here ok so you can see now that's
actually a really good question you know
how I drew a horizontal line before I
draw a horizontal line here across that
one and I'm also going to draw our 1
here it negative 1 right so small means
between these values right less than 1
bigger than negative 1 these values here
these small values they're going to get
even smaller anything on the outside so
you have a look over here right this is
a one and a half one and a half squared
is two and a quarter it's up there right
big values get bigger small values get
smaller as some of you predicted because
this is a straight line right when you
square it you're gonna get a parabola go
ahead finish the shape say it again
okay just here right so there's the
original function right here it's
negative 1/2 I'm squaring the function
negative 1/2 times negative 1/2 equals
1/4 which is right there see that
oh you following so now we're ready to
actually draw this thing right
do your best go through all of your
points there you go what do you think
how'd you go did you get your shape
there look at okay so there's my
parabola okay I squared it
okay now this guy here just pay close
attention because last time I gave you x
squared plus 5x plus 6 this is actually
a different parabola I've done that very
much on purpose okay
let's think again about those critical
spots start telling me where are those
important values okay let's let's go
four negative one so then what happens
when you square that it becomes one
there's one so I'm gonna give you
another important value when y equals
when y equals to zero when you square
zero what happens you get zero where are
the two spots yeah just it's not quite
it's actually weird scale but you can
see where they are right there and there
okay now now it starts to get a little
bit tricky watch out here okay see here
I drew these red lines right I'm gonna
ask you to draw these again I'll make
mine a bit thicker so you can see it a
bit more clearly
[Music]
okay now between these red lines right
between the red lines I have what I'm
calling small values of X small values
of X get smaller when you square them
right so I'm gonna get really teeny tiny
for example let's pick a spot like right
there I'm picking this spot because what
does that Y value look like that's 1/2
and I know what 1/2 times 1/2 is it's
1/4 so I'm gonna put in there's well
there it is 1/4 is about zero point
there right there okay now you can see
there's another spot over here see
that's also 1/2 so when you square this
1/2 what do you get 1/2 times 1/2 it's
still same thing it's still a quarter
right like right right about there's the
half there this is weird this thing is a
weird shape you'll see why in a minute
okay go and have a look for some other
important spots right I can see there's
another 1/2 here what happens when you
square that it's a quarter and here
where'd it go I lost it there that's
negative 1/2 what happens when you
square it a quarter right like so so
just have a look at these X's that looks
weird right I'm gonna have to like kind
of wiggle around to hit all of those X
it's gonna be a weird dr. Don okay so
that's what's happening on the inside
yep
you turn around this one here okay again
I'm gonna ask that same question right
what's this Y value this is a half so
when you square a half what do you get a
quarter there it is okay it's always
looking vertically right it's always
looking vertically so that's why this is
vertical this is vertical this is
vertical right so that's what I'm
looking for okay it's tricky sonna sorta
okay it has some real similarities but
there are some been pointed differences
okay any other important points that you
can see important values we did negative
one we did zero kind of another one
missing what's after negative 1 and then
0 1 there's just one we did zero right
where is it 1 here on my red line and
over there on my red line what's 1
squared 1 so I'm gonna go through here
and here
what is this shape it's it is exactly
that okay now I'm gonna do my best
just watch carefully right by the way
you know how says symmetry right
symmetry symmetry in the original is
going to give you symmetry in the square
for this right I'm gonna do my best
I don't promise a miracle but here's
what I think I've gone
that's one side okay so this guy is
weird right
do you see how weird it is but in some
ways it should be exactly what you
expect for starters you're squaring it
right so you notice how everything is
above the x-axis everything's positive
and that's kind of what as parents say
this is kind of what it shares in common
with an absolute value right you square
stuff and get positive values out okay
but yeah it gets all these weird like
Wiggles around now you shouldn't be that
surprised because what was the original
function what did it look like it was a
parabola right so has an x squared or
some kind
we just squared and x squared thing so
you're like oh this is an extra power of
not two but four and that's why it
Wiggles around so dramatically okay